[Music]
okay so we're here in the high tunnel
now we're going to plant some of these
Atlantic dill giant pumpkin seeds and
first thing we do is get you a container
this is a four by four it's good enough
that'll work
we're just gonna fill it with some
potting soil here nothing special about
it this nice moist right out of the bag
and then what we're gonna do is just
want to poke a little hole on your
finger just like it planting any plant
just put a little hole in it they're not
very deep just enough to cover the seed
with soil is all we want to do and these
seeds are nice size seed they're real
fat and they're real heavy seeds they
have kind of a rounded end and they also
have a pointy end here the pointy end
goes down kind of important to note
these seeds have been soaked in water
for about four hours prior to this to
give them a good drink of water
just put them in a glass of warm water
about a hundred degree water just let
them sit there for a while and they'll
draw in a bunch of moisture so those
have come out of the glass of water
they're nice and wet and they're gonna
go right down in here in the soil I'm
just gonna put them in their pointy end
down and just deep enough that the soil
covers them that's all they're all we're
gonna do and we don't want to Pat it
down real tight
and then we're gonna give it a little
bit of a drink of water get the soil
nice and moist we're not gonna water
that again until the plant emerges
that's all it gets right there with what
it soaked up from being soaked in the
water and then a little bit that's
stored in the soil that's all its gonna
get from here it's gonna go into the
germination station over here we'll put
it on the heat mat and under the cover
and then we'll wait it stays about
depends how cold the room is but it it
stays around 78 to 80 degrees in there
it's just a 17 watt map it's warm to the
touch but it doesn't not like it's
really warm you're gonna burn anything
it might be in the 80 degree range at
all and these seeds have been taken
about a week they've come to the topsoil
they've emerged and they're ready to go
oh as soon as they come through the soil
we want to turn the grill light on so
they've got as much light as possible
otherwise we get a real long leggy stem
and we can run into all kinds of stem
problems like that one
if they don't get enough light as soon
as they emerge so for the first 48 hours
after they come to the SOI I like to
leave the light on 24 hours a day to get
that that third leaf that first true
leaf to where it's starting to emerge so
we don't get a real long stem on it
plant like this it emerged about a week
or so ago and what we're gonna do with
it is we'll let him stay in here for
maybe another week someplace around two
weeks as soon as we've got this first
true leaf established and we know where
it's going to go if the weather permits
it's time to go outside and let's get
them out there and get them transplanted
as soon as possible is less shock to
them when they're a lot smaller like
this and they seem to recover a lot
better than trying to transplant the big
plants they they grow fast in here but
it's really hard to transplant them when
they get big they're better to do it
when they're small and let them take a
hold out in the patch
[Music]
this here these first two leaves are the
emerging leaves and this next one coming
up that has the little ruffles on it
this is called its first true leaf and
we can tell which way the vine is going
to want to grow based on where this
first true leaf comes out the the vine
will want to go 180 degrees from here so
the line is going to want to come that
way from here this this leaf will lay
back and the vine will come out in this
direction and that will give you a
little bit of an idea when you put it in
the ground you can train the vine to go
wherever you want but it makes it a lot
easier and a lot less stress on the vine
if you get it pointed in the general
direction that you want it to go and
it's telling you where it's going to go
by where this first true leaf comes out
at
[Music]